Your Heroes are always anti-heroes
they're almost always villains yeah they
actually really try to have morality not
even be an issue at all all right when
it comes to my character that's so
interesting I mean you know I don't want
that to have any play whatsoever I that
would be me commenting on them that is
me sticking my big nose into their lives
and then their philosophies I let them
be who they are I mean you're you're
Heroes it's not dark exactly because
they're kind of weirdly light villains I
mean in terms of their happiness with
villainy you wouldn't call them classic
heroes and you know my biggest feeling
is I just want the same rights that a
novelist has I mean look we live through
the 80s we're like [ __ ] every
Hollywood movie everyone had to be
likable and everybody had to be
understandable and I didn't make movies
at that time but I was watching them and
I'm not gonna make that crap and
um and I just want the same Freedom that
a novelist has I mean you can make a
novel you can write a novel about a
bastard but it can be totally
interesting